all right have a great show I appreciate
it well I'm Jason japitz in for Laura
Ingram and this is a special edition of
the anger mangle from New York City
tonight
there was a time in politics when
disparaging half of your fellow
countrymen especially if you sought to
lead them was political suicide
a 47 comments are not going to help Mitt
Romney's popularity 47 is is bad enough
It's haunting Romney and his campaign it
has been a brutal week from Mitt Romney
in the wake of his 47 comments recent
events and mistakes on Romney's part
have hurt him with them specifically the
47 comment he made in Florida and things
like that 47 comment they really do have
the potential to hurt
but of course for Democrats the rules
they're always different after calling
half of the country fascist I mean I'm
sorry
semi-fascist then last week Joe Biden is
somehow able to turn around and blame
the right
remember what used to be the criticism
of Biden was running
Biden's too bipartisan
Biden has too many republican friends
there's a lot of Republicans
I've worked with all the years in the
Senate I got a lot done
we respected each other when we
disagreed we disagreed on principle we
never went had lunch together not a joke
what in God's name has happened to that
in the United States of America
and if he thought he might use his
speech today in Wilkes-Barre
Pennsylvania to turn down the
temperature think again his smear
campaign against his fellow Americans is
showing no signs of slowing down
for those Brave right-wing Americans who
say it's all about
shaping America you're keeping America
is independent and safe if you want to
fight against the country you need an
F-15 you need something a little more
than a gun
no I'm not joking think about this think
about the rationale we use that's used
to provide this and who are they
shooting at shooting at these guys
behind me
so just to recap Joe threatens his
fellow Americans with F-15 Jets and then
accuses them of indiscriminately
murdering folks that's pretty low even
for Joe hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else